a fait le choix des députés utile je
pense que vous savez personne même les
gens qui ont on a tous entendu pendant
pendant cette campagne des élections
législatives beaucoup de beaucoup de
colère c'est que s'est exprimée de jeu
qui se traduit peut-être par d'ailleurs
les bons scores du rassemblement
national ou de houe delà du ps mais pour
autant je pense que le message que nous
envoyer nos concitoyens c'est aussi
d'être d'être tous utile d'essayer de
nous de nous entendre au maximum pour
pour défendre leurs intérêts c'est ce
qu'on essaie de faire les mesures que
vous c'est que vous évoquez la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires qui va être plus
importante le rachat des rtt le
doublement du chèque carburant donné par
qui peut être donnée par les employeurs
sans fiscalité là encore évidemment elle
sans charges sociales pour l'employeur
tout ça ce sont des mesures que nous
avons mis sur la table la déconvenue
gallisa sion dahache qui permettra aux
allocataires d'âge de ne plus être
dépendant du niveau l'allocation adulte
handicapé et handicapées qui permettra à
ses bénéficiaires de ne plus être
dépendant du niveau de revenu de leur
conjoint toutes ces mesures là c'est des
mesures qu'on a mis sur la table depuis
cinq ans depuis cinq ans la majorité
étaient fermés moi je me suis plutôt
satisfait que enfin enfin la majorité
ressentent la nécessité de nous de nous
écouter je pense que c'est utile aux
français